- He's a singer, songer, record
producer, dancer and actor.
- People call him the King of Pop.
- His 1982 album Thriller,
is the best selling album
of all time.
- He's Michael Jackson
and here are his top 10 rules for success.
- [Interviewer] My favorite
song on the album is
Man in the Mirror.
- Oh, yeah.
I liked that a lot.
- That's my favorite song.
I tend to hold a feeling
that no matter what you do in the world,
it has to start with you.
- It is my philosophy too,
if you want to make the
world a better place,
take a look at yourself and make a change.
- Is it hard to do?
- Yeah, well, people don't
look at themselves honestly.
They don't look at themselves
and point the finger,
it's always the other
guy's fault or somebody.
You should change yourself
and look at yourself.
Make better of yourself.
My purpose?
Oh, boy, I think to give
in the best way I can,
through song and through
dance and through music.
I am committed to my art.
I believe that all art
has as its goal union
between the material and the spiritual,
the human and the divine.
I believe that to be the reason
for the very existence of art.
I feel I was chosen as an
instrument to give music
and love and harmony to the world.
I remember having the guys go back in
and create more innovative.
This is our thing, we don't put
a lot of sounds on the album
that are sounds from keyboards
that are pretty much
programmed into the machine.
We go out and make our own sounds.
We hit on things, we beat on things.
So nobody can duplicate what we do.
We make them with our own hands.
We find things and we create things.
That's the most important thing to me,
to be a pioneer, be an innovator.
Okay.
(beginning of "Billie Jean")
- [Interviewer] What's
going through your mind
when you're dancing?
- I'm not thinking.
Thinking is the biggest
mistake a dancer could make.
You have to feel.
("Billie Jean")
You become the bass.
You become the fanfare.
You become the clarinet and
the flute and the strings
and the drums.
- So you're almost the physical
embodiment of the music?
- Yeah, absolutely.
("Billie Jean")
Believe in yourself.
Study the greats and become greater.
No matter what.
I don't care if the whole
world is against you
or tease you or say you're
not going to make it.
Believe in yourself.
No matter what.
Some of the greatest men have made a mark
on this world were treated like that.
You're not going to do it.
You're not going to get anywhere.
They laughed at the Wright Brothers.
They laughed at Thomas Edison.
They laughed at Walt Disney.
They made jokes of Henry Ford.
They said he was ignorant.
He didn't have a college degree.
He dropped out of school,
Disney dropped out of school.
They even took Ford to court
to prove his intelligence.
That's how far they.
- Really?
- Yeah.
These are men that changed
and shaped our culture,
the way we do things.
Most important, stay humble.
The humbleness of a child,
that a newborn baby has.
Even though you become
powerful or have power,
with people, with your talent,
like what Michelangelo did with sculpting,
underneath all that, be as
humble as a child, as a baby,
and as kind and giving and loving.
Never become puffed up with pride.
- How do you write a song?
- How do I write a song?
Well.
If I sat down at the piano,
if I sat here and played
some chords, whatever,
and said, I'm going to
write the best song ever,
nothing happens.
Something in the heavens has to say look,
this is the time that this
is going to be laid on you
and this is when I want you to have it.
Now I remember when I wrote Billie Jean,
I was riding in my car,
down Ventura Boulevard.
All I said to myself beforehand,
I want to write a song
with a great bass hook.
I just let it go.
Several days later
(hums Billie Jean)
- Where did that come from?
- From above.
- So okay, you were singing the bass line.
Sing that again and then what happens?
Do you get the other
instrumentation and the composition?
How did it work?
- The thing is,
artists seems to get in
the way of the music.
Get out of the way of the music.
Don't write the music, let
the music write itself.
With any type of creation, you
create what's inside of you.
Subconsciously, what influences you.
I'm a fantasy fanatic.
Anything that take you
off into another world.
Escapism.
That's what I like.
I'm not so crazy about
the reality of everything.
I like a lot of fantasy.
And that's what I try to create.
To get away.
To become moved.
♫ To become moved.
I think what they get
from me, I get from them.
I've said it many times,
my greatest inspiration comes from kids.
Every song I write, every dance I do,
all the poetry I write, it's all inspired
from that level of innocence,
that consciousness of purity.
Children have that.
I see God in the face of children.
Man, I just love being
around that all the time.
- [Interviewer] You have
something within your records
that everybody just loves.
- Boy, I couldn't say.
I just created it
and I'm honored that the
public enjoy what I do.
I couldn't explain the
anatomy of why it happens.
- There's a formula?
- Not that I know of.
Just my heart, I put my heart in it.
- You put your heart in it?
- Yeah.
Like Michelangelo said, you know,
I know the creator will
go, but his work survives,
that is why to escape death,
I bind my soul to my work.
And that's how I feel.
I give my all in my work,
cause I want it to just live
and just give all that I have, you know
and it has to be.
- [Interviewer] What do you put into it?
- Well, whatever I sing,
that's what I really mean.
Like if I'm singing a song,
I don't sing it if I don't really mean it.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Random Order asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Michael Jackson's top
10 rules you like the most.
Leave it below, I'm going
to join in the discussion.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.